well first of all i think this deal
represents one of the most
comprehensive free trade agreements ever
signed
and it's a good deal for british
families
businesses and jobs it gives us a
fantastic platform
to go forward maintain tariff-free
access to european markets but also
capitalize on new opportunities
whether that's signing new trade deals
and we've already signed i think 58
covering about 200 billion pounds worth
of trade with more to come
or trying new things like free ports for
example
which will create jobs drive investment
and increase trade
so all of that is exciting to look
forward to
but in the short term our challenge
remains for dealing with coronavirus
making sure that we've got economic
support in place for british families
and businesses as they go through what
is a difficult winter period
well i think there were always going to
be people who want to reopen the debates
of four years ago but i don't think that
would be the
right thing to do i actually think this
deal can represent an enormously
unifying
moment for our country and bring people
together after the divisions of the past
few years
for those who voted to leave this still
means that we will have the freedom that
people sought control of our laws our
borders our trade
but for those who were anxious about the
economic
implications of leaving they should be
enormously reassured
by the comprehensive nature of this free
trade agreement
ensuring tariff-free quota-free access
for british businesses to the european
market
ensuring that close economic partnership
and crucially protecting british jobs